He sees you when you were sleeping.
He knows when you're awake.
He knows when you've been bad or good,
so be good for goodness sake.
If you live in the western world,
you already know this line from Santa
Claus is coming to town by Harry Connick
Jr.
We've all heard the songs
and seeing the movies,
but do you may not know the true story
behind the legend of the man who can fly
around the world in just a single night?
Any mind?
They'll be wondering,
why am I wearing a hat that is not a
Santa Claus hat and that is because for
this very special Christmas video,
I wanted to get a Santa Claus hat,
but apparently I have a giant head and
this Christmas tree house was the only
thing that would fit me.
I'm going to take this off and we're
going to get on with today's video.
Nicholas of Bari was born in the
fourth century in the town of Myra,
located in Asia Minor.
This is now modern day Turkey.
His parents were wealthy Christians who
had trouble conceiving a child for many
years.
They prayed to God every day to
have a child if their very own,
and as soon as they finally
conceived and gave birth to a son,
they saw it as Trudy America.
Sadly Nicholas's parents,
they would die of an epidemic that spread
throughout the city of my relieving
him to become a young orphan.
He was raised by his uncle,
who was the bishop of Myra,
who would never had children of his own.
He was very proud of his nephew,
especially when he grew up to
be a very well behaved boy.
His uncle apparently announced to everyone
in the church that he had a vision
that his nephew would grow up
to bring joy to many people.
When Nicholas grew up,
his uncle's prophecy
actually did come true.
He was always kind to others and twin
town of his way to help people as an
orphan.
Nicholas had a special place in his heart
for children and he would often help
them make handmade toys to play with.
Even though he was from a wealthy family,
he still had a lot of sympathy for the
poor and he wanted to do whatever he
could to help.
There was a man in the town who
had three beautiful daughters,
but he was so poor he
could not pay for a dowery.
This meant that his daughters could not
get married and so they would have to be
sold into slavery because the father
could not afford to support them.
Nicholas wanted to help,
but he did not want to hurt the father's
pride by offering a donation face to
face,
so he dropped a bag of
gold down the chimney,
which lands in their stockings
that were hanging up to dry.
The father and his daughters,
they jumped for joy,
believing that God had finally
answered their prayers.
He was finally able to pay for the dowery
and all his daughter went on to get
married.
Nicholas came back to do this again
for the two younger daughters,
which is when he was caught in the acts.
Everyone knew this gold wasn't just
appearing out of thin air and people began
to whisper around town.
About a young Nicholas and his
kind heart and his generosity.
Nicholas was a very simple person who
didn't need a lot to be happy and the
money didn't mean much to him,
but he knew that his donations could
be life changing for other families and
Myra,
he just sent me did to continue paying
attention to people who needed the most
help in the city and he would always
anonymously give away his inheritance,
have a people off to this story
spread around town people again,
Z,
leave that stockings and shoes by the
fireplace in hopes that they would receive
gold from Nicholas as well.
Soon Office of this,
people throughout the city of Myra were
receiving anonymous presence that would
mysteriously appear in their homes.
This box has spirit of giving a neighbors.
We're now helping out one another in
that time of need without fear of hurting
that pride.
Anytime an anonymous gift would show up,
they designed it to thank Nicholas.
Even if he wasn't the ones who
actually deliver every single present.
People begin to remove that since this
man seemed to be able to be in many
places at once,
he was more than just
a devout Christian men.
They believed that he had been
blessed with magical powers.
Now he truly did begins you travel across
Turkey and he reached a point where he
had given away all of
his earthly possessions,
which was totally fine with him.
He at that point,
is devoted his life to becoming a monk.
We know with absolute
certainty that Nicholas truly
was a real person because he
grew up to take over his uncle,
his position as the next bishop of Myra.
There are records of his participation
in the first council of Nicea,
including his outspoken outrage over
the corruption that he saw within the
Catholic church.
In one story,
Nicholas witnessed a horrific scene where
children had been kidnapped since he
was then able to rescue them.
He was seen as such a hoodie man
that he was the nature canonized,
a Saint Nicholas,
the patron saint of children,
and surprisingly sailors.
That's right,
Saint Nick.
I love to travel.
Even back then.
He sailed along the coast of Asia.
Minor ins dreamed of
seeing the entire planet,
so he has to come sailors,
which continue to pray to some Nicholas
to help them whenever they were on a
long voyage.
Legend has it that one day
Turkish sailors were out at sea.
The winds and waves were so strong that
the men were afraid that the boat would
capsize.
They prayed to Saint Nicholas for
help and he appeared before them.
With his arms outstretched.
He was able to control the weather and
it's calm the ocean and the sailors made
it home safely.
This was just one of the many examples.
If the stories of Nick's
extraordinary magical powers,
and it just may be a good explanation
of how center managers to travel in his
sleigh through all kinds of weather,
the fantastical stories of Sedna,
this loss did for longer
than just one lifetime.
Historically didn't need to go
on for another thousand years.
It would seem that the magic behind
his generosity was so inspiring and
powerful.
It was enough to keep them alive in the
hearts of mankind for generations to
come.
From the fourth to the 16th centuries,
Nicholas became one of the
most popular Catholic scenes.
People continue to pray to him,
wishing for his help
in their time of need.
As time went on,
he preferred to receive
letters rather than press.
It was probably much easier for
him to keep records this way.
Stories of cynics magic and generosity
began to spread throughout the rest of
the wells.
In the Netherlands,
Belgium and Switzerland.
Children began to leave the shoes
outside on Saint Nicholas Day,
so the to the Jolly Sinta class
could leave them presence.
Sure enough,
small toys and candy were left for them
when they work in the morning after the
Protestant reformation,
Martin Luther,
I wanted to do away with the
stories of Catholic saints,
so he said that these presence were
actually coming from the baby Jesus or
Christ candle.
People were confused,
of course,
because they knew that the real
gift giver was the Jolly old son,
Nick,
delivering the presence to these children.
So Christ Kendall was misunderstood
to be Kris Kringle Lens.
The nickname stock after
the revolutionary war,
there was a movement to reject many of
the English ways and start new traditions
the way uniquely American and author by
the name of Washington and I haven't had
already made a name for himself by
writing and publishing American folk tales
that had been told by word of mouth,
like Rip Van Winkle Lens,
the spooky legend of sleepy hollow.
This became a Halloween classic.
So when he heard about the
Dutch story of Sinterklaas see,
decided to officially give him the
properly American sounding name,
Santa Claus.
This is house and Nick officially
became a part of the American Christmas
tradition.
Either the next few hundred years the
public would learn more about Santa Claus
then they had known before in 1809 I
haven't wrote in his book knickerbockers
history of New York about a surprising
Santa Siting in central park.
It read the good Saint Nicholas came
riding over the tops of the trees in that
selfsame wagon wearing.
He brings his yearly presence to children.
He went on to explain the sense it took
a break to smoke his pipe of tobacco
before getting that in his wagon.
Then flying away.
Fortunately,
as you might imagine,
modern sensor has given up smoking,
but he hasn't replaced it with
a serious cookie addiction,
so it's not exactly kind on
his ever expanding waistline.
As the years went on,
more and more writers would elaborate
with additional details and now sound to
goals.
In December of 1823 a writer named Clement
Clarke Moore was walking through the
snow on his way home under his arm.
He had a Christmas Darcie for his family
and looking around at the beautiful
scene,
he was suddenly inspired to write a poem.
It titles of visit from Saint Nicholas,
but you probably know that as
the night before Christmas.
It was the night before Christmas
when all through the house,
not a creature was stirring,
not even a mouse.
The stockings were hung by the chimney
with pat and the hopes that Saint
Nicholas,
which soon
this became an incredibly popular poem.
It's so perfectly captured the Christmas
spirit so that in just a few years,
nearly every American
would know it by heart.
Instead of thinking of his time living
in Turkey as a fourth century St people.
Now Imagine Santa clause to be a chatty
jolly old man who climbed through the
chimney to place presence in stockings
and leave them wrapped up under the
Christmas tree.
So I said Nick had always been a sailor
and as an avid traveler throughout his
lifetime.
Now the gauging the open
sea is no easy task,
especially before the benefits of gps,
but he wants it to get around
on land at a much faster pace.
In 1921 and anonymous author wrote and
illustrated a story called old Santa
Claus with much delight.
For the first time the public learns
that center had upgraded his ride from a
rickety old wagon and is
a boat to a proper sled,
pulls by a single raindance.
In 1889 poet Katharine Lee
Bates introduced the world
to Mrs Clause and we got
to know,
and it's a bit more about
some next personal life.
We still don't know exactly
when they got married,
but this couple have what is probably
the longest lasting marriage in history.
We also don't know if they
ever had any children together.
As the years went on,
the public learns more about centers,
progress in his mission to
bring joy into the world.
We learned that he moved his new secret
hideouts to the North Pole and he hired
a team of elves to run his workshop.
We were introduced to his extended fleet
of eight magic reindeer and in 1939 he
added to the newest member of the
team Rudolph the red nose reindeer.
In 1891 even the presidents of the
United States was promoting Santa Claus.
Benjamin Harrison told the breasts,
we shall have an old fashioned Christmas
tree for the grandchildren upstairs and
I shall be the Santa Claus Myself.
That's me hope that my example will be
followed by every family and the land.
The very first video footage have captured
of Santa Claus was in 1898 by a film
maker named Je Ne Smith.
The wells could see him leaving presence
for sleeping children on Christmas Eve.
Of course,
as time went on and modern
technology improved,
more and more people were
capturing footage of Santa Claus.
It was finally time for him to come
out of hiding and make his first public
appearances.
Moving into the 20th century,
it sounds a clause was always hip to
the modern times during the industrial
revolution.
He was able to improve as operations with
as Elf employees working the assembly
lines in his workshop at the North Pole
sound the game more like the CEO of his
toy empire,
making sure the operation
run as smoothly as possible.
Now that he wasn't
running as workshop alone,
he was finally able to make the time
to begin making public appearances.
In 1924 he decided to be a part of the
Macy's Thanksgiving Day parade in New
York City.
It received such a warm welcome from his
adoring fans that he decided to reapply
every single year ever since.
So long as the organizers meet the demand
on his ride or to provide him a tall
glass of milk and some warm chocolate
chip cookies in the green room in the
1980s brought the boom of the shopping
mall in the United States and this began
the tradition of Santa Claus taking
personal requests from boys and girls.
There is even a massive party gold Sandvik
on held every year in New York City,
which isn't even a real convention.
It's just an excuse to dress a
and nick and party in the streets.
There is also the livable Santa Dash
and so many other events all around the
world that are thrown in is on that.
Moving into the 21st century,
modern technology has helped us truly
break down the science of just how center
manages to make.
As Jenny,
you can track some nicks progress on
Google maps is Santa Tracker and in 2016
the Mira did an intensive study of this
statistics of centers magical Jenny.
On Christmas Eve.
They discovered that in order
for him to deliver presence,
you every single child in
the weld on a single night,
he would need to travel at
speeds of 1,280 miles per second.
Even though the world love Santa Claus,
that doesn't mean his legacy has been
free from controversy in he is often for
being at the root of making the holiday
season about material things rather than
having young people remember
the true meaning of Christmas.
Commercialism is a very
real thing of course,
and there is no denying that Santa Claus
has helped sell billions of dollars in
products every holiday season
from Coca Cola to Barbie dolls,
let's say no wells where religion
and politics divide so many people.
There are very few things that Americans
agree on quite like the tradition of
Santa Clause.
Every December the 24th children go to
bed and they wake up at the crack of
dawn,
hoping they will find presence
underneath that Christmas tree.
For many.
It's one of the very few
memories we all share rough.
Having faith in something
and the experience of
childhood wonder and it's the
belief in magic,
but sometimes it sends a close call and
do everything by himself and he needs to
recruit help in unexpected ways.
Just one example of this was
in 2011 a young couple names,
Jim and Dylan moved into their new
apartments on West 22nd street in New York
City.
Then they started to get letters in
their mailbox address to Santa Claus.
They thought it was a joke of course,
and they went to the post office to see
if there was a forwarding address for
the previous tenants.
They were told that yes there was,
but it was simply push as
the north pole that fast.
They didn't know what to do with these
letters and they had no idea how these
random children got their address.
They even 30 such for why on Google.
Eventually they decided that they
could not ignore these matters.
Many of them were heartbreaking matters
that came from underprivileged children,
Dylan and jammed against you,
parse out letters to their friends
and coworkers who all shared in the
responsibility of buying
presents for these kids.
Soon enough what spread on Facebook
and they were able to get hundreds of
letters fulfilled by
kindhearted volunteers.
They now run a charity called miracle on
22nd street where anyone can volunteer
to help out with the letters to Santa.
If you're still unconvinced in
the existence of Santa Clause,
there are few words that can
better express the truth.
Then those are Francis for solace church.
In 1997 and an eight year
old girl named Virginia,
a Hanlon wrote to the New York Sun saying
that I have friends in school told her
that Santa Claus was not real.
She asked the church to tell her the
truth and they published this reply.
Yes,
Virginia,
there is a Santa Claus.
He exists is short or his generosity
and devotion exists and you know their
bounds and give to your life.
It's highest beauty and joy.
Alas,
how dreary the world would be without
to Santa Claus and just era biographics.
We want to say that Santa Claus does
exist as long as he's in our Haas and with
that very merry Christmas
and happy holidays.
Yup.